[Music]
if nobody is illegal then what exactly
is going on with the channel migrant
Crossings
[Music]
so over the last few years migrants have
been crossing the English Channel on
small boats to seek Refuge here in the
UK in 2022 alone there were 45
000 men women and children who crossed
the channel in a small boat to enter
Britain now entering the country in this
way is illegal but many have argued that
because it is in order to seek asylum in
the UK it cannot be illegal now with
such a high Asylum Grant rate for these
types of migrants it's obviously no
surprise why people would want to risk
the perilous Journey so according to the
government there are currently a number
of safe and legal routes to seek Asylum
even though they're quite limited some
of these routes are restricted to people
from specific countries such as
Afghanistan and Ukraine while other
routes only accept limited numbers so
currently there is the UK resettlement
scheme which prioritizes those from
regions and conflict there is the
community sponsorship scheme which is
for local community groups to provide
accommodation and support for refugees
there's the refugee family reunion for
partners and children under the age of
18 of those who've already been granted
protection in the UK and there's also
the Mandate resettlements came aim to
resettle refugees who have a close
family in the UK who can offer a home
now the government insists that the UK
operates safe and legal routes with the
unhcl however the organization insists
that there is currently no mechanism
through which refugees can approach this
organization with the intention of
seeking asylum in the UK so why does the
situation seem so bad with these migrant
Crossings at the moment migrants are
being housed in crowded detention
centers on barges and in hotels at Great
cost of the country the overwhelming
situation has meant that the government
is spending upwards of 6 billion pounds
a day to house these migrants and the
slow processing times has meant that 82
percent of Channel migrants who applied
for Asylum since 2018 are still waiting
for even an initial decision one of the
problems we see with this debate is the
prevalence of the phrase no one is
illegal it's become popular amongst
groups of people who have advocate for
refugees and migrants present in the
country unlawfully in the case of
migrants crossing the English Channel
it's been used to advocate for these
people to be allowed safe Refuge here in
the UK but saying no one is is illegal
it's like saying no one is
photosynthesis it's empty it's
meaningless and it's also misleading the
definition of illegal in the case of
boat migrants is anyone entering the
country outside of immigration controls
that means not entering via an official
Port of Entry like an airport it's like
someone entering through the back door
instead of the front and I know there's
a joke in there somewhere but my mother
is watching unfortunately for the
Bastion of competence that is our home
secretary she's failed to stress this
point and this has meant that the
national conversation around these
Channel Crossings has moved from the
impact on society to how mean we are for
demonizing poor migrants so here are my
takes on what's wrong with the current
situation so firstly they're effectively
jumping the queue which is a cardinal
sin to any Brit so why should people
entering the country illegally be
allowed to do it how is it fair that
people who have the ability to pay
people Smugglers to Ferry them across
the channel from France or Belgium in
order to take advantage of our lacks
broken Asylum system deserve more
sympathy than a widowed mother stuck in
Syria now I'm not saying these people
are unfortunate or even desperate and
unlike many of the pundits monopolizing
this conversation I've actually seen
what real poverty and Desperation looks
like surely by virtue of being able to
jump the queue in this way there are
more people who are deserving of British
Hospitality what about the people who
don't have the resources to even make it
to Europe in the first place
unfortunately some people just don't see
it that way the second problem is who
are these people and what values are
they bringing over what if some of the
migrants in question are homophobic or
has it never occurred to people that
some of these migrants from certain
parts of the world may not have the
warmest feelings towards gender pronouns
or pride month or transsexuals I knew a
man growing up who made the trip across
the Mediterranean who ended up not in
the UK but in Europe and trust me when I
tell you he would not be looking very
fondly on anything to do with LGBT
related issues are those the kind of
people that we should really let into
the country without vetting them we
cannot be this naive it's no surprise
that people who reduce this debate to no
one is illegal pay little attention to
the issues of social integration social
cohesion and National Security in
communities who experience a rise in
these types of migrants in screams of
extreme privilege and entitlement and
yet the same people have the audacity to
posit themselves as champions of the
working class unlike many countries in
Europe who have ID card systems the UK
does not this has meant that many of
these migrants that are released into
the country get lost in the underbelly
of society without any way of tracking
them we don't know who they are we don't
know where they are and we don't know
what they believe you know who gets the
most annoyed by illegal immigration
legal migrants that's why it comes as no
surprise that the new one is a legal
Brigade have never actually had any
interaction with the British immigration
system maybe just maybe they need to
queue for hours in the blistering heat
of Accra outside of the British High
commission for them to really understand
how infuriating it is when people
trivialize the process and experience of
migrating to Britain it's a it's a Pity
that it takes someone from the outside
to make people really understand how
much of a privilege it is to live in
this country despite all of its problems
so currently what's being done about the
child of Migrant Crossings is the
illegal immigration bill now once it's
operationalized the illegal migration
act will mean that people who come to
the UK illegally will not have a right
to stay and instead they will be liable
to be returned either to their home
country or relocated to a safe Third
Country Now the new legislation also
prevents people who come to the UK
legally from misusing Modern slavery
safeguards and introduces a law to stop
them making spurious legal challenges to
frustrate their removal now in my
opinion this is a step in the right
direction of course it's not perfect the
shadow secretary Yvette Cooper raised a
very valid point when she said that the
lack of return agreements with other
countries will just increase the Asylum
backlog with even more people in costly
hotels nonetheless I love living in this
country and I'm extremely grateful but I
don't want to see this country destroyed
by people who don't even realize what a
privilege it is to be able to live here